قصف تجدد على قطاع غزه في عدد من الاماكن
من اهل الجباليه او بيت لاهيا او بيت
حانون
مراسل الجزيره والي الدحدوح موجود في بيت
لاهيا شماليه قطاع غزه
وهذا كما نشاهد واحد الاماكن التي طالها
القصف الاسرائيلي
هذا صحيح عثمان هذا هو البيت الذي تابعنا
عمليه تدميره من قبل الطائرات الاسرائيليه
ونحن نتحدث عن تشييع القياده في سرايا
القدس اياد الحسني
وانتقلنا من جنازه التشييع الى هذا المكان
لنرصد كيف تحول هذا المكان تشاهدون ربما
عدسه الكاميرا ما الذي حدث ليس فقط المنزل
لكن حقيقه مربع سكني في هذه البلده
الوادعه بلده بيت لا هي تحول الى اثرا بعد
عين تشاهدون حتى المنازل المجاوره هي
الاخرى اصبحت غير صالحه للاستخدام ولا
للسكن وغير قابله للحياه لكن اذا
قدرنا عدسه الكاميرا تجولت بشكل واضح ربما
تشاهدون بقايا هذا المنزل هذا هو منزل على
يقع على زاويه مقبره بلده بيت لاهيا
بجواره تماما يوجد قبر تم تدميره خلال
عمليه القصف وتدمير المنزل لكن هذا القبر
هو الذي يتضح من هذه الزاويه في قلب
المقبره هناك عدد كبير من المقابر وجدت
نفس المصير تدمرت والحقت بها اضرار كبيره
جراء عمليه القصف قصف هذا المنزل هذا
المنزل لكم ان تتخيلوا هو عباره عن منزل
مكون من طابقين
واصبح ليس فقط سوته بالارض ولكن ربما هنا
حفره عمقها لا يقل عن اربعه او خمسه امتار
بطبيعه الحال
دفنت الركام حتى لم تحوله الى كون من
الركام وانما دفنت الركام في باطن الارض
وربما تطايرت بعض الشظايا والركام وكميات
كبيره جدا من الرمال الموجوده في هذه
المنطقه واقتحمت البيوت المجاوره كما
تشاهدون هذه البيوت ايضا لم تعد صالحه
للسكن نهائيا لان كثير من الجدران
والاعمده
ومحتويات والاسس حتى تزلزلت وتحطمت وتدمرت
وبالتالي لم تعد صالحه للسكن والاستخدام
هذا البيت يعتبر تتويجا لسياسه تدمير
المنازل قبل هذا البيت كان نحو اكثر من
عشرين منزل لاقوا نفس المصير
واصبحوا عباره عن كومه من الحطام الان هذا
المنزل ومنزل في الزيتون
ومنازل اخرى ايضا في مناطق وبالتاكيد
القائمه تطول وبالتالي الخسائر يعني تزداد
شيئا فشيئا ونحن نريد ربما ان نرصد
اللحظات التي عاشتها اسره او اصحاب هذه
هذا المنزل من هذا المنزل او المنزل
المجاور يعطيك العافيه الله يعافيك اول
شيء زي ما بقولوا المال معوض ايش اللي صار
معكم الحمد لله احنا بالبيت اتصلوا على
اخوي صاحب البيت قالوا له معاك المخابرات
اخذ البيت قال لهم انا يا عمي ايش بايش
انا اعمل البيت قالوا بدك قال له انا
بالنسبه الي انا طالع بدي ابلغ
في البيت ولا حوالي البيت قال له ماشي
اتصل باخوي التاني قال له بدي مربع كله
المربع كله تخليليه قال له طب اعطيني
الهدف يعني الهدف اللي بدك اياه قال له
انا مربع كله بالداخليه فبلغنا الجماعه
اللي حوالينا والاطفالنا ونساعدنا كله
طلعناه طبعا
لا يعني ما خويته ولا اغراض ولا اي شيء
مستعجل اللي موجود طلع بملابسهم اللي
عليهم وطلعوا في الشوارع
ربنا يعوضكم على العموم هذه ربما جزء من
المشاهد التي عاشتها هذه الاسر ليس فقط
كما قلنا اصحاب هذا المنزل ولكن اصحاب
المنازل المجاوره
ابقى معنا سنعود ابقى معنا سنعود